we have this interesting segue from this
conversation into ukraine surprisingly
but it you know i guess in this day and
age with a story from a business insider
how a transgender ukrainian man
escaped russia's invasion
i painted my nails violet and wore mom's
shirt to look more girly we then have
this story from tmz
transgender woman i'm fighting two wars
in ukraine fears russians and
transphobic ukrainians
so this is interesting because in the
story about the trans woman in ukraine
because of the war they announced if you
were 16 was it 16 to 60 year old man you
could not leave the country
legally in ukraine a trans woman is a
man
whatever your political opinion is on it
that's the view of the ukrainian
government i do think it's funny that
the left is just like totally on board
with ukraine
i get it you know the russian invasion
is a bad thing but you got like nazis
there and it's like the government is
transphobic but whatever so you have the
story where this trans woman is like you
know i'm a woman and i can't leave
because of this rule then you have this
other story about a trans man so this
person is born female
paints their nails and wears feminine
clothing to be able to escape the
country
to me it's interesting you know i'm
wondering there have been a lot of men
males who fled ukraine as well as as
well as women like the titanic right i
mean and i understand if someone's like
i don't want to fight in a war and they
want to get out but this is like your
country is being invaded the interesting
the interesting thing to me is i
understand these are two unique
individuals we're not talking about a
group here but it is fascinating the two
stories we get out of here are about a
biological male and female a trans man
and a trans woman both trying to flee
the country and not stay and fight for
it yeah i mean it the headlines
interesting isn't it fighting two wars
actually they're trying to not fight any
right
right exactly not the gender war not
anything we
we talked about um
thomas i think it sounds pronounced this
is the
biological male uh trans woman who's
competing against females in college
swimming
yeah yeah but there's also a trans man
so someone born female who got top
surgery and competes against isaac
hennig isaac hennig at yale so so my
issue is it's it's i mean obviously the
ukraine thing is a situation of war life
and death so i'm like hey anybody who
wants to get out and is worried we
should help these people um when it
comes to the college swimming thing my
question to the left which they have no
answer for and they just insult me uh is
okay so if you're saying that a trans
woman is a woman and then should be
allowed to compete in the women's
division because the woman's division is
a social construct division right and
say yes okay well isaac is a man
identifying as a trans man therefore
they shouldn't be allowed and they say
but isaac's not taking testosterone
right that's the excuse so so we're
talking about bio biology or or society
they don't know well whatever suits
their argument well it all flows in one
direction like when you whether it's a
trans man or a trans woman they're both
trying to find a way to leave the
country the trans woman says but i'm a
woman you can't say i'm a man the trans
man says i'm gonna paint my nails and
wear women's clothing trying to
understand is why is the person who is
female but um
trans as a man
why do they have to do anything
like if they're a female why wouldn't
they just walk over the border so so the
so this i mean because
if you're a female right you can have
short hair and you can i know this is
crazy but you can wear a suit you could
wear button-down shirts you could wear
men's shoes if you're a female and it
doesn't change anything about being
female i haven't heard that you can even
keep your fingernails super short yeah
and unpainted and you still are female
no no but i i think
one of the big issues in the culture war
is that you know whatever our faction is
we assume too much about the other
side's beliefs and understandings of
things
i think it's fair to say that they don't
think that a woman can have short hair
or do these things
well now if a young girl
says i want short hair and i want to
wear blue jeans they ask the child if
the child is trans right they don't know
what they do yeah they don't they don't
say well maybe you just like short hair
it's become like if you act
this is the strange thing to me about it
maybe i should understand that if you
have a child who says a little boy says
i like dolls then all of a sudden you
have conversations about whether the
child's trans when the child doesn't
have an understanding of sexuality
because they're prevubescent right and
they just like stuff right and you don't
even know why they like stuff like maybe
they like dolls because they like the
color or the texture
you know or being able to tell stories
with dolls in their trucks i don't know
sure stick in their truck so you know
whatever it is but we don't ask children
what it is that they like yeah sometimes
the joints of the doll are what make the
doll cool doesn't have to do with like
if it has blonde hair as a girl i had
one where you press the button on the
back and she winked at you
it was western barbie matt walsh brought
this up um after the uh the dr phil
thing he did he was he said if you know
his if if a little boy or his son came
to him and said that he thought he was a
girl he said we'd ask him why and often
you'll hear him say things like i want
to play with dolls and he was like but
boys can play with dolls too sure it's
funny because hearing matt talk about
stuff like that that's like that that
used to be progressive that was the
original that was like much the feminist
perspective right if you're a woman you
can dress and behave however you want
you can dress the way men
stereotypically dress you can behave the
way men stereotypically behave you can
do any of that right you can sleep
around you can do whatever
it's fine
uh and now we've switched all that up
we have we have taken the gender
stereotypes and embedded them further
yeah it seems like the modern uh
progressive left's world view is that
there are social behaviors intrinsic to
sex
yeah i'm confident i'm just confused i'm
just i don't understand there was a
there was a case uh discussed on the bbc
and uh
a little boy lived with his mum
and she had two towels after she had a
shower for her hair and her body
and one day he said i'd like two towels
and she said you don't need two towels
so
he said but i'm a girl
and so she went to bed that night and
thought deeply about him being a girl
not that he just wanted two
damn towels
um and then he started on his road to
transition at like seven
socially transition that's a mess up
it's just so weird my son uses like four
towels i don't know what he did with
four
i come into the bathroom i'm like you
really needed all these towels why did
she say he didn't need two towels though
he has hair right
i have no idea this is her this is her
very brave journey about discovering
that her son was really a girl
and so
i think she was a good thing to say
i think the question is you know
what about this child saying that they
were a girl
is is like
confirmation of a trans identity i mean
obviously for her like right so like
what what makes you think
from saying i want two towels to saying
that you're a girl
makes the leap to their biology is wrong
and they need medication or some kind of
surgical treatment right i mean it would
i'm assuming that she went to the doctor
though right for me
if we
assume she hasn't got
something like munchausen's by proxy
um
there is a lot of social status for
average people to gain by doing this
brave and super wonderful mother
and it is women unfortunately it's women
that that go along with this narrative
with their kids it's not so much dads
well it's sort of a feminist fascism
yeah so you know where we have taken the
ideas of feminism and we now impose them
by force
i don't i don't i don't think words uh i
think this is probably intentional but
words have almost no meaning at this
point
what is feminism that was intentional we
were actually before we went on tonight
um kelly and i were looking at the
definition of gender and gender identity
on um what like wax law i think at
cornell
and they're this they're the same
they basically have the same definition
which were gender identity gender and
gender identity are all about like your
perceived self and your innate internal
self
which doesn't which isn't anything like
it's just absurd we've taken and we gaze
in so deeply that we think we see
something and it's not i just try to
avoid all of that social argument stuff
by just saying sex well that works out
so i'll say like
male and female instead of men and women
and then i'm just like there you go fine
whatever it still doesn't work with
canadian hate speech laws really but
we're in this really bizarre sort of
idea that our bodies are not connected
to who we are i mean i am my body
if i was if i was taller i'm sure i'd be
slightly different if i was a lot
shorter i mean i don't know if that's
possible but if i was
if i was shorter i'd be a completely
different person of course if i was a
man walking around in the world with a
testosterone and b
being a man and being treated like a man
there's a there's a trans um there's not
a trans there's a transaction between me
and the society in which i live and we
both kind of find out what and who i am
it's not just up to me and it's not just
up to them
and it's bizarre that we're deciding
that gender is separate from that your
internal sense of self is a social
construct is the most stupid idea and it
doesn't make any sense you know i was
just thinking about someone in prison
and maybe how because people are
adaptable and their sense of what i am
like in prison they're like what do you
what do you even think i what are you
who are you and then you beat the hell
and like when people are getting like
sexually assaulted in prison and like
over and over and over and over again by
some big guy and it's a guy and he's
like i'm not gay but i have to create a
new reality for who i am in this
situation
and so they create like a new gender
almost to to exist within that without
being insane
so i understand that
the people that that's happening
to people i think it's uh honestly if
you zoom out i think it's happening
because like there's so many people on
earth
misproportioned in cities and all these
phenolphthalates in the water and and
pharmaceuticals like making people
androgynous and making people kind of
it's like shaving off conspiracy theory
i don't know it just seems logical isn't
that isn't that true though that birth
control is in public drinking water yeah
pharmaceuticals go into the toilet in
the pee when people pee them out after
they eat the prozac and then that gets
in the water supply people are all
really really messed up and it might
just be a process of the human race kind
of shedding its skin
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you